c'est là que j'habite c'est pas
le curé il habite la maison qui est
juste là départ et voilà où ça et là je
vais prendre le petit déj des fois et
voilà c'est la carte
lie à perpignan en fait en fait voilà et
lie à marseille et on espère que zidane
il est rappelé à paris zinédine zidane
pourrait devenir le prochain entraîneur
du paris saint germain alors que
l'information est pour le moment
démentie par les proches du footballeur
c'est un crève coeur pour la ville qui
l'a vu naître mars est dans le coeur
urbain on peut pas partir à paris c'est
impossible c'est une vraie masse et
partira pas il ya trois choses qu'il
faut pas toucher à marseille la bonne
mère le vieux port et l'om mais quand
c'est idem et que tu reviens pas ça fait
mal comme je pense que c'est un très bon
joueur très bon
malika on vous sent très concentré
quelque chose à dire sur le shopping
d'alison peut-être ça c'est un shopping
de provence alpes provençales vous
voulez dire provincial tout ça parce
qu'elle y sommes viennent de bordeaux
mais quel est le problème avec la
province je trouve que la provence elle
a un temps de retard sur la mode on a
dit la province malika à la provence
mais la province appréciera votre
remarque alors il ya la platine ya le
micro en plein milieu de table un vrai
mais cros moi je sais que c'est un faux
des énigmes des quoi est visible les
gros disques de l'époque john allen à
des vinyles apparu au début des années
50 le vinyle est composé de deux faces
grave et il est destiné à être lu sur
nos platines tourne disque ou
électrophone elle est décédée et on
reste dans l'univers musical avec bob
sinclar qui nous a livré les secrets de
la création de son tube love generation
ah le miracle de la création or c'est
bon ça attirait en tirer
on dirait que c'est toi quand il était
dans ce monde étrange ans directeur a
toujours été là
anne veut vérifier que les pôles et bien
remboîter mais le gaz anesthésiant amis
le patient dans un état second
bouger le bras levé
je lui qu'un problème c'est là le drame
celui là le droit
du milieu le droit vous pouvez vous eu
l'épaule
la sq intéressant c'est que vous êtes
intéressés et une étude sur le muscle a
raconté absolument alors le musc vous
savez la sarcopénie je sais pas si ça
vous dit quelque chose c'est
l'affrontement nuage je vais le noter
parce que ça fait très intelligent la
sarcopénie sarko n'en seul mot ça
existe a franchement tu es très joli
tout ça et ça te dirait pas même
peut-être qu'on aime prendre un verre
chez moi et de sable il dit est sérieux
ou pas à maints pays pourquoi avec kindy
on a accouché en sommes à ce dernier
[Applaudissements]
ça prouve que j'ai bon goût jeu the
brave
tu vois pas qui était derrière tout
envoyer passion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
on a nos gagnants c'est vraiment aimé
les deux clébard la
droite millionnaire faut encore une fois
trop de bisous et j'ai passé de fès
oubaïdi c'est un pas de fait stohellou
ah oui c'est vrai qu'en plus de la
famille kardashian le rappeur booba
c'est votre référence philosophique
malika donc
pour traduire si t'as pas de fesses tu
as rien c'est ça
le 12 le 12 aides à démouler le flanc
[Rires]
lingerie
j'ai très envie d'envoyer un message à
tout le répertoire de laëtitia mais
il faut qu'on trouve une idée de
messages envoyés alors les parents tu
déconnes par
ce mal me connaître
quoi tu envoies un message c'est plutôt
bonjour ou coucou coucou plutôt coucou
coucou
1,290
350 être dans le tech
alors 300 euros à lecce la jolie marie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de chez
vous non c'est non non non je lis et moi
non je rigole
[Rires]
discret mais ça va casser les couilles
depuis quelques temps tu as un
depuis quelques temps tu a mauvaise
haleine
[Applaudissements]
comptes tu faire
c'est urgent non eh ouais c'est
l'urgence accra je t'embrasse
de loin
à l'eau est ce que tu m'entends
mais si tu m'as tort que tu me dis pas
d'attaqués commando
basque à ce mot
parce que la chaîne s'est dit on lui a
mis pierre tchernia ça a marché on va
lui mettre pascal sevran pour la fureur
j'ai perdu pour l'afrique touche lui
voit la chanson française
asseyez-vous me suis jamais autant
éclaté qu'avec ce gars il avait sa
bouteille de rosé bien frais avec des
glaçons il avait deux exigences il
fallait qu'il est toujours du roseau
frais et qu'on ne parle jamais de
vanessa paradis